hi guys sci-fi recap here before we
start
warning spoilers ahead today
i'm going to explain a 2019 american
superhero horror film called bright burn
set in a fictional town called
brightburn the movie follows tori and
kyle breyer
a young couple who lives happily with
their only son brandon
all seems to go well at first with
brandon appearing to be everything they
dreamt of
a happy curious and intelligent young
boy
in the classroom brandon seems to be
smarter than other classmates
because of his high level of
intelligence he often gets bullied by
his envious friends
but there is a girl caitlyn who always
keeps embracing him
he then falls in love with this girl
what at first appears to be a gift from
heaven soon turns out to be something
monstrously as the boy begins to show a
sign that he is different when he turns
into 12.
the spaceship begins to transmit an
alien message causing brandon to
sleepwalk to the barn and act strangely
he tries to open the cellar as something
is hidden in there but then his mom
intervenes and takes him back to the
house
starting from that moment brandon begins
to exhibit superhuman powers
the next morning he attempts to mow the
lawn but when he tries to turn on the
machine
he unintentionally tosses the lawnmower
surprised with the power
the boy puts his hand in the spinning
blade and immediately breaks it without
having his hand injured at all
the next day his parents decide to take
brandon camping
before leaving kyle finds his child
acting strangely while eating breakfast
as brandon bends a fork with his mouth
while cleaning up brandon's room taurian
intentionally discovers photos of sexy
models and graphic photos of human
organs
misinterpreting the photos they found
before as pubescent curiosity
kyle gives his son a small talk when
hunting to give him understanding about
sex
his dad explains that sex is not about
organs and other stuffs
but it's about a love between two people
unfortunately
this talk only inspires brandon to sneak
away at night and goes to stalk his
beloved classmate
caitlin which then leaves the girl in
shock at one night after the family
comes back from camping
kyle spots his son staring at chickens
and notices that the chickens are
terrified of brandon's presence
he then brings the boy back to the house
later at night
the parents are awoken by their screams
only to find out that they had been
killed
although kyle tells tori that their son
is responsible for the killing
she refuses to accept the fact that
brandon is capable of such things and
keeps saying that it was caused by a
wolf
one day during playing a trust game at
pe class where a person falls and the
other friends must support the falling
person
brandon falls towards caitlyn but the
girl refuses to hold him and lets him
fall to the ground
not only that the girl also accuses him
of being a pervert
having previously seen him in her room
at night she is forced by the teacher
to help brandon up but brandon who is
already frustrated by her action
crushes her hand this accident makes him
suspended from school
that night brandon once again sleepwalks
to the ship and manages to break the
lock on the cellar door where the
spaceship was hidden
seeing red light emanating from the barn
tory follows and sees her son levitating
while chanting a message from the ship
take the world
brandon then falls down and cuts himself
on the ship revealing the kid's weakness
when tory calms her son down she reveals
the truth of his origins
she tells brandon that he is not their
biological children rather
they found him in a strange spaceship
that crashed into their property 12
years ago
although she and kyle have lied about
adopting him from the agency he is still
their son and they love him very much
after knowing the truth brandon runs
away in anger while chanting the alien
message
this is the moment when he completely
turns into a psychotic serial killer and
discovers his new power for being able
to burst a red flash from his eyes
the killing begins with caitlyn's mother
erica who has forbidden him from seeing
caitlyn ever again
brandon finds erica alone at the dinner
and begins to scare her by covering the
window with his signature symbol
he then shatters the light above her
causing one of the shards to strike into
her eyes
she screams in agony as she tries to
remove the piece of glass
with blood obscuring her vision erica
then runs towards the storage room and
locks herself inside
with his superpower brandon manages to
break in and decides to kill the poor
lady
the next day police find a series of
runes drawn on a window while
investigating erica's disappearance
at school brandon meets his aunt merrily
who is a school psychologist
she gives brandon a chance to redeem
himself after the incident at pe class
as she is required to update the boy's
condition to the school
his parents and to the sheriff but
instead
he keeps ranting about being special and
is showing no sign of remorse at all
unhappy with what merely said earlier
brandon visits his aunt later that night
and tells her that it's not a good idea
to talk to the sheriff and threaten her
she refuses to fulfill his demand and
tells him to go home
but does he really go home when she goes
to bed
noah merrily's husband comes back home
and finds brandon hiding in the closet
with his creepy mask
noah is furious and tells brandon that
he is going to report everything to his
parents
because of that brandon lashes out and
pushes his uncle away with his
superpower
noah then tries to drive away but
brandon lifts his car up and drops it to
the ground which ends up killing his
uncle
before he goes away brandon's draws his
signature symbol with his uncle's blood
returning home topless he tells his
parents that his friend had ripped the
shirt off while playing soccer after
school
somehow brandon does not let his parents
take the shirt
at midnight merrily calls tori and kyle
to inform them about noah's car accident
and tells them that their kid had been
sneaking around in her house
the next morning tori announces noah's
death to brandon
but he shows no reaction at all towards
the news brandon tells his parents that
he would never hurt his own uncle
but kyle accuses his son of lying
unhappy with his dad's reaction
brandon's triggers his power and
violently throws his father up against
the wall
kyle then finds out his son's
bloodstained shirt and shows it to tori
she refuses to believe that brandon is
the culprit behind his uncle's death's
case
realizing what his son is going to be in
the future kyle plans a hunting trip
with brandon as a ruse to kill the boy
when in the woods kyle attempts to shoot
brandon in the head with his hunting
rifle
but the execution fails as the bullet
bounces off brandon's head
feeling betrayed by his father brandon
then chases him and kills him directly
with the heat vision
the police who is investigating noah's
case realizes that there's a similarity
between his case and erica's missing
case
he then decides to visit briar residents
and ask story if he could talk to
brandon to clarify the strange symbol he
found earlier
but tori states that the kid is not at
home and tells the police to go away
tori finds brandon's notebook with
drawings of his murders and his message
to take
the world having seen that tori starts
to believe her husband and tries to call
him
but brandon answers the call instead and
implies that he is coming for her
although tori immediately calls the
police for help brandon flies home and
begins to destroy the house
he also brutally kills the police and
his friend remembering that the ship can
injure brandon
torrey runs to the barn and unexpectedly
discovers erica's eviscerated body
nailed to the wall
after arming herself with a fragment
from the ship she approaches her son and
tells him that there's still good inside
him and expresses how much she loves him
she then tries to stab him but brandon
sees that coming and manages to avoid
the stabbing
in retaliation brandon flies tori into
the sky above the clouds and drops her
down to her death
just as an airplane approaches the next
day
an airplane is revealed to have
mysteriously crashed destroying the
whole property and killing everyone on
that plane with brandon as the only
survivor
during the credit scene brandon begins
his worldwide attacks and starts to
dominate the world
as the world starts to learn his
misdeeds and his infamous reputation as
a menacing force grows
he's branded with a new name breitburn
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching